The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BOB JONES: I was working
in this consulting firm.
I got bored.
I wanted to go start
a business, and I
said it's not like
I'm in my dorm room.
It's not like I haven't
done this before,
so I need to be sensible
about it this time.
Because I've had
start-ups that succeeded
and start-ups that failed, and
I like the successes more than
I like the failures.
So I interviewed a bunch of
people, scientists, marketing
types, et cetera and came
up with about 15 ideas
and said that's too many.
I need some filters.
The first filter was I need
to solve the right problem,
because I'm good
enough at operations
that I'm going to
hit the target.
But it's embarrassing if
you pick the wrong target.
So my definition of
the right problem
is that you would cheerfully
pay for the solution
and you will tell your friends.
So I can lower your
cholesterol with
a nutritional intervention.
It's not the right target,
because you don't care.
You'll forget to take it, your
medication, most of the time,
and you're never going to talk
about it with your friends.
And I can't afford to educate
you, because I'm a start up.
If your back hurts, ooh, that's
a whole different matter.
Because if I can help
you with something
that makes your
back stop hurting,
you will cheerfully pay for it.
You will tell your friends.
And if furthermore
I can set it up so
that when you stop taking my
stuff your back starts hurting,
that's the right target.
Second filter, I have to
be able solve the problem.
So if I had an enzyme
that metabolized gluten,
I would be speaking to
you today from my yacht.
So that one's off the table.
That killed all but
about five of the ideas.
The remaining filter
was somebody besides me
thinks this company
is a cool idea
and will buy it if
I don't screw it up.
So the last thing I did was
took the remaining ideas
and called some senior execs
that I was friendly with,
had companies that
could, well, one day
buy the business-- Procter
& Gamble, Johnson & Johnson,
Pepsi, et cetera-- and
said, I'm having some ideas.
I'd like to hear your
thoughts on them.
I'm not selling anything.
Well, I knew you
were up to something.
What are you doing?
And when I would
offer an idea, if I
would hear crickets and--
OK, on to the next idea.
That's how we arrived at sleep.
There's somewhere between 50
and 70 million people in the US
that have trouble sleeping,
and they complain about it.
And nobody has to tell them
the benefits of a good night's
sleep.
Everybody just feels
better, and there
are nutritional interventions
that will solve the problem.
And the companies
I talked to said
if you don't screw this up,
we'd like to be first in line
to talk to you in
about two years.
So with that as background,
I had several businesses
in the past where we
made nutrition bars
and sold them
through clinicians.
So my business model was
let's make a nutrition bar,
and let's sell it
through clinicians.
But I talked to a
number of consumers
and said, how do you feel
about eating something
at 10:00 or 10:30 at night
that will have you asleep
a half hour later?
And most of them said I don't
feel so good about that.
I don't like the idea
of eating something.
OK, what would you like?
Well, you know those little
5 Hour Energy drink things?
Make me one of those, except
with the opposite effect.
Oops, looks like I'm in
the beverage business.
OK, well so maybe
what I can do here
is find the clinicians that
you are seeing about the fact
that you're having
trouble sleeping,
and I can do what I did before.
My business model will be I
will call on the clinicians.
The clinicians will
say, this is fabulous.
I will tell my patients.
The patients will
want to buy it.
One day I will call Walgreens.
We'll stock it there.
We've done this before.
You may remember
a little while ago
I said I had a really bad five
or six weeks where everybody
told me no.
I called doctors, nurses,
physical therapists,
dietitians.
I went to assisted living
facilities and retirement
communities and talked to
resident care directors.
And without exception,
I was told no.
People don't talk to
their doctor about sleep.
They talk to their doctor
about their ear ache.
If they do talk to their
doctor about sleep,
the doctor runs for
cover, because he doesn't
know how to solve the problem.
And he's been trained that this
is a symptom of something else.
You are depressed and
you need a therapist,
or you have sleep apnea and you
need one of those Darth Vader
devices that blows
positive air pressure
and it keeps you
from having apnea.
So let's refer you to
somebody else next.
So nobody was willing to
talk about our intervention.
This was the point--
at this point,
we had made our
minimum viable product,
and we were offering
free samples.
And they didn't want
it even if it was free,
so clearly the business
model was flawed.
We weren't going to be able to
get it into Walgreens or places
like that if we couldn't
find any customers.
And the route I had chosen
to get to the customers
was not working.
Nevertheless, there
were people who
were calling us back and buying
our minimum viable product.
The one that looks
bad tastes bad,
and because the little
manufacturer spilled
a little solution on the threads
and it dried into something
like superglue, you need a
vise grips to get the cap off.
People were buying it anyway.
Clearly we had
something there, so it
was time to address the business
model of what is it we have,
and to whom should we be
marketing it, and how.
Along the way I ended up in a
conversation with Whole Foods.
Because when I was running
a soy foods company
I sold a lot of tofu to
them, and I knew them.
So I thought, oh, OK.
We'll put this together.
We'll sell it
through Whole Foods.
But who is our customer?
We did a lot of work,
a lot of interviews,
got told no some
more and concluded
that there are a number
of niche markets here
that we could work with.
But the one where we were going
to start was working moms,
and not working moms who have
infants or toddlers at home.
They expect to be
tired, and they
want to be able to wake
up if the baby's not
sleeping through the night.
So forget it.
But once their kids are
preschool, kindergarten,
or older, they've got
the hardest job on earth.
Most of them have
husbands who don't shop,
don't cook, don't pick up their
socks, so they're hardworking.
They're daytime professionals.
They're fussy
about what they buy
and what they
bring in the house.
They do shop at Whole Foods.
It looks like the
right market for us.
So in my conversation
with Whole Foods,
I was pretty direct
with them and said,
look, I can live a
long and happy life
and never put my
products on your shelf.
The moral of the point, I
don't want to be on your shelf
if it doesn't make sense.
So really the purpose of
this meeting in my view
is to figure out will
it ever make sense
and if so, what's
the trigger point.
And the answer to that was
when we see enough reorders
through Amazon to show
that there's a there there,
come back and see them.
Keep them posted.
They'll remain interested.
We are after all friends,
and it's a provocative idea.
So the revised business
model now having
gone through this
postulate the idea,
develop a minimum
viable product,
shake it down in
the marketplace,
identify the target is
we're reaching working
moms via mommy bloggers.
We've identified 100
of them, some of whom
have as many as
100,000 followers.
There's also all manner
of social media ways
to reach working moms.
So working moms,
we're reaching them.
We're selling the product
through our website which
will be a minuscule
percentage and through Amazon
until such point as we have
enough of a reorder stream
to make a justifiable
approach to Whole Foods
and other retailers.
Shortly after that, we
hope to sell the business.
So Rich, that's sort of an
impromptu summary of how
our business model
morphed and pivoted,
and it's a work in process.
So if you don't have anything
else to do, wish us luck.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BOB JONES: Thank you.
PROFESSOR: So the
reason I wanted
Bob to tell you about
that is to reemphasize
this is not just an
academic exercise.
He told you about how
he succeeded before.
He told you how he
failed the first time.
He did something
different the second.
He took the second model
into the third market,
which turned out not to be the
right thing for that market.
And he's reinventing it.
And it's been an
interesting thing.
So what we say up here,
we're not giving you
a formula on how to do it.
We're trying to get you to think
about these kind of issues,
and this is an example
of an in-process thing.
And it's been an
interesting route.
Bob, any other comments or
people from the audience?
BOB JONES: It's
practically a reality TV
RICH KIVEL: What were
some of the learnings?
It sounds like you modified
the business model throughout.
There were learnings
[INAUDIBLE] You integrated
different approaches.
What were some of the learnings
that came out of that?
What would you have
done differently
if you were
relaunching it today?
PROFESSOR: Rich, is your mic on?
BOB JONES: OK.
Rich's question,
for those of you
who may not have heard it
from the back of the room,
was what were some of
my learnings so far?
And if I were to relaunch the
business today, what would
I do differently?
And I think that most
entrepreneurs are stubborn.
I'm no exception to that.
Well, you almost
never tackle something
that's going to be easy.
And I have a guy on my
business advisory board
who will give me 10 reasons why
every idea I have will fail,
and why every suggestion
I make is dumb.
And it's quite useful because
eight of the 10 things
he'll rattle off, I've
thought about and addressed.
And two of them I think, ooh,
I'd better think about that.
But you have to be willing
to walk through walls
because it's hard.
And most of you will fail.
I did.
You'll just need to
decide that as a jockey,
you need a different horse.
But I found something
that worked.
And I went out and
proudly talked about it
to the investment community.
And then I tried it.
And I tried it.
And it didn't work.
So one of the things I
would have done differently,
were I to do it
again, would have
been to test the idea
right from the get-go,
rather than just assuming
that because it had worked
in the past, that this market
and this group of people
was like the last market and
the last group of people.
PROFESSOR: That's great.
BOB JONES: Yes sir.
AUDIENCE: It seems like
most of it is [INAUDIBLE]
BOB JONES: I don't really
know how to do that.
What I like is
translating science,
which is somewhere near
to the leading edge,
into something that
consumers can buy.
And I don't want to get
metaphysical with you here.
But I think there are some
really fundamental things
wrong with our
health care system.
And we don't often enough
provide consumers with stuff
they can buy, which works,
without a prescription.
And I like being in that arena.
And I like being able to
understand what consumers want
and translating some
fairly serious science--
it's pretty sophisticated
biochemistry
in our little beverage
for sleep-- into something
that we can describe without
going into all the science.
So I actually don't know.
I don't really
have any experience
selling the one-off stuff.
So with that as background, I'm
going to duck your question.
I don't know.
There was maybe one more.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BOB JONES: We had three
ingredients in the product.
And there were published
papers on the action
of each of the three.
So sucrose gets
metabolized here.
Protein gets metabolized here.
And gluconeogenesis runs through
the liver, blah, blah, blah.
And uncooked corn starch
with its complex double bonds
takes a far longer period
of time to metabolize.
And we would show the
papers to the clinicians.
And they'd say, well
this is a no-brainer.
First of all it's just a food.
So it won't hurt you.
It costs $1.00.
Might help.
Go for it.
That was all the
resistance we found.
There were maybe
3% of the doctors
out there that we
called on who said,
when you got a clinical
trial on it, call us back.
And we did in fact eventually
do a clinical trial
with the Joslin
Diabetes Institute.
It did what it was
supposed to do.
But as an entrepreneur,
I was unwilling to wait.
Let's get in the market.
My measure of whether or not it
works is, do they reorder it?
PROFESSOR: Hey.
Thank you, Bob.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, so now segueing
from what Bob told you
about he's doing to find
customers and everything,
the question again
is business models.
And tonight we have Rich Kivel,
who I've known for many years.
Originally an internet IT
technology entrepreneur,
moved into the
medical area and bio,
and more recently into the
financial technology area.
So Rich Kivel-- his
bio is on the website.
And his topic is
business models.
Take it away, Rich.
RICH KIVEL: Thank you very much.
Great.
Can everybody hear me OK?
All right.
It's great to be back here.
I've had the privilege of doing
this class with Joe for-- he's
invited me back for many years.
I won't say how many,
but many, many years.
So it's also great to be here,
being the 25th year of it.
Has anybody here actually
attended this class before?
All right.
That's good.
So I could tell some
of the same jokes.
And I will actually get laughs
out of them. [INAUDIBLE]
So first of all, I
want to start off
because I love social media.
And I'm going to include
you in my social media
life a little bit.
So everybody here
uses Twitter, yes?
Or most of you?
That's our hashtag.
So on the count of three, I want
you guys all to cheer and yell
in a congratulatory way for
Joe celebrating the 25th year
of this class, all right?
One, two, three.
AUDIENCE: [CHEERING AND YELLING]
RICH KIVEL: You guys.
I love it.
Joe, that is live.
That was outstanding.
So what I get to talk about
today is actually kind of fun.
It's business models.
And unlike a lot of
aspects of business,
business models themselves,
they change all the time.
And as a matter of
fact, they become
an incredibly intricate
and important part
of how a business succeeds or
fails, which is something new.
As I've worked around MIT for
the past 15 or more years,
so often the
researchers, scientists,
engineers that I speak with are
so focused on their product,
their technology,
the intricacies
of a particular design,
that they actually
don't think about the customer.
And they don't think
about how it's ever
going to get to the market.
They're more interested
in can they actually get
that new particular
engineering-physics combined
technology to do something
they never did before.
Can they get that
particular molecule
to operate in a certain way?
Or can they get that
thin film polymer
to elude a particular drug?
And that's fantastic.
But very often we
forget about how
do we actually impact the
world with our technologies,
whether it be internet
technologies, applications,
hardware, software,
biotechnology.
So business models are really
the foundation of that.
And very often that's
left to business students.
And one of the wonderful
things about MIT
is that there's this
great convergence, where
business students
actually have discussions
with engineers and scientists
and researchers and vice versa.
And that doesn't
happen everywhere.
So we take it for granted here.
So I'm very privileged
to come and talk
to you about business models.
My background, as Joe said
is-- I started my career
in technology, and
then moved very much
into bioscience, biotechnology,
bioinformatics, diagnostics.
I spent about the past
10 years doing that.
I took two years off, and
was focused specifically
on the financial
services industries.
So I worked for a very large
fund in Westport, Connecticut.
Now back in the Boston area.
And now focused again more on
not only funding and financing
of early-stage
development companies,
but also in identifying
great intellectual property
and technology, all-around
science and research.
So today's talk is going to
be about business models.
And I'm hoping to share
some insights with you.
Essentially this is how
I think of these things.
We start off with a whole
bunch of disparate data points.
We call that information.
Hopefully we begin to
connect those dots.
It's almost like a
pointillist painting, where
you have thousands of dots.
And then slowly as
they come together,
they start to connect.
And then ultimately out
of that, you have wisdom.
You have an image that
is created out of that.
What I hope to do
today is provide you
each of those three--
information, knowledge,
and wisdom.
So let's start off with
a simple foundation.
And the foundation is to
say this-- many definitions
of a business model exist.
The one that I like the most
is simply this-- a method
by which a firm uses
its resources-- cash,
technology, its people-- to
offer its customers better
value than its competitors,
and make money doing so.
It tells who pays how much,
and how often do they pay.
For those of you
that are looking
to start companies, or even
begin to work for companies,
especially
early-stage companies,
the question that the
board, the investors,
the new employee coming in
the door are going to ask
is, what do you do?
Who do you sell to?
And how do you make money?
It's pretty simple.
The how do you make
money part is often
the challenge for
many start-ups.
They have very cool technology.
They think they know
who's going to buy it.
But they have no
idea how they're
going to get it in the
hands of those individuals.
Are they going to
create a website?
Are they going to join--
sign on to the app store?
Are they going to go retail?
Are they going to
use a distribution
channel or partner?
That's the big crux of it.
So that's the question you have
to continue to think about is,
how do we ultimately make money
from what we are developing?
So what's changed
a lot in the way
we operate in this world is
the way that companies operate,
the way that companies
are formed and developed.
And this chart is not really
meant, in great detail,
to be read.
But overall, what
you have here is
an example of how over time, you
have points of history where,
as industries
developed, changed,
they went away, what you had is
different ways of communicating
with the world, different
ways of actually connecting
with consumers.
If you think about back in the
days of merchants and mechanics
and industrial
businesses, the way
they operated and communicated
was much different.
Retail stores existed, but in a
very, very, very different way.
They were family-run stores.
Most of the products and
services we bought from
were from a few large
retailers like Sears,
whether that be your
washer and dryer
or your tools or other things.
As technology continued
to mature, what you saw
is the financial service
industry becoming very, very
sophisticated.
And the financial
service industry
began to allow us to see
business in a global way.
Out of that came complex
advertising campaigns,
global marketing and
distribution mechanisms.
And what you saw is entirely
new ways to buy and reach
the end user, the products.
What really changed is,
at this end of the world,
where you had technology, was
then introduced in such a way
that distribution of goods--
ultimately the ability
to connect an individual
who wants a product
or service to that
product or service--
the barriers of distance,
the barriers of manufacturing
suddenly went away.
The United States has
probably done this better
than almost any
place in the world.
We can get something
delivered tomorrow
that we ordered this afternoon
at 11:00 AM or 1 o'clock
in the afternoon, whether it be
a product or service, because
of financial support and
backing for those type
of organizations, whether it
be the manufacturers, the UPS,
the FedEx, and others.
The distribution channels
have shrunk greatly.
When I travel to different
parts of the world,
they find an amazing selection
of products and services
that we have in
the United States.
And when you go elsewhere,
you notice how limited it is.
If you're living
in parts of Europe,
if you're living
in parts of Africa,
parts of Asia, if you're
living in most of Russia--
the ability to actually
order something today
and see it arrives in the next
month is very, very unlikely.
And the more remote you
are, the less likely
it is it's ever
going to reach you
on time, or without
being lost in some part
of the distribution channel.
So I encourage you
to think about,
as technology has changed
and distribution channels
have changed, it has
impacted the way that we
operate and build companies.
So at MIT, when we
think about how do you
bring a company from
the idea to the market,
or what is so often called
the lab to the market, the way
you think about that has to
integrate the business model.
So for those of you here that
are scientists or researchers
or engineers, as you're thinking
about your new products,
your service, or
your technology,
you have to continually test
who is going to buy this.
How am I going to get
it to the consumer?
How will this ultimately impact
the people that I care about,
the people that are
going to benefit
from my product or my service?
Just as Bob was
sharing with us--
before-- some of the learnings
he had as he was developing
his new company, were
those bumps in the road
as they realized that various
ideas they had about, hey,
we'll give it away for free.
Or perhaps we'll go through
this particular distribution
channel.
Those things did not work.
You learn from those.
You incorporate.
You speak to more consumers.
You speak to more investors
that are expert in the space.
And you modify your approach.
So as all of you think about
building companies, products,
and technology, think
about how are you
getting it to the consumer.
I think the mistake that
a lot of people have is
they think that as they
read The Wall Street
Journal or Bloomberg
or MSNBC is,
they hear about the
stories of these companies,
and the stratospheric
growth of these companies.
But they think success is
this linear process, when
it's really not.
Success is really messy.
It's noisy.
There's lots of bumps, lots
of failures and challenges,
whether it be because of
market acceptance, technology
failures, or it
happens just simply
because the market was not
ready for what you were doing.
The goal is for
you to figure out
throughout those
bumps and those curves
how to identify
opportunity, and also
how to modify your
products and services.
So that brings us to
business models in general.
There's lots of different
ways to think about a business
model.
Complexity was famous for years.
I remember when I was
in graduate school,
they would talk about
business models, sales
and marketing and distribution.
And it was mind boggling.
If they pass it out on
an 8 1/2 x 11 sheet,
you would need a magnifying
glass to figure out what was
happening because the
distribution channels were not
as sophisticated.
The technology was
not as sophisticated.
So you had complex models.
And within these
complex models, there
were lots of points
of failure, lots
of points where your reseller
or your OEM channel--
your original equipment
manufacturer--
or your distributor
was failing, lots
of points where the
manufacturing was not
succeeding or the retail
environment was struggling.
So what's happened is you've
seen simplification of business
models-- these ideas that
become simplified in such a way
where you say to yourself,
I'm building this,
and I want it to be in
the hands of these people,
whether that be a consumer, a
doctor, a lawyer, if it happens
to be a large corporation.
What's the easiest
way to get there?
And leveraging
technology, leveraging
all of those things
that are out there,
including the good advice
of experienced people,
will help simplify this.
An example might be
Zipcar, a company
we're all very familiar with.
This is a relatively
simple business model.
It almost seems so
simple that you'd
be amazed if you presented
this to an investor and said,
this is our model.
This is it.
And we're going to build
basically a company
worth-- a publicly traded
company-- I don't even
know what the market
cap is at right now.
Fantastic, successful
organization,
operating globally in many
cities around the world.
They kept it very simple,
very organized business model.
How many people
here use Dropbox?
You get 2/3 of the group
here that use Dropbox.
When's the last time you saw
a Dropbox advertisement on TV?
It doesn't exist.
20 years ago, if you were
looking to build a company,
you'd have to have an
advertising budget.
You'd have to think
about how we're
going to wind up getting
this into the hands
of the right people.
Who are the right people?
Are we going to
sell to businesses?
sell to individuals?
What's Dropbox's business model?
How come you guys know
so much about Dropbox?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH KIVEL: How was that?
Word of mouth.
Other people told you.
It's viral.
So somebody tells you
about this incredible thing
called Dropbox.
You can sign up for free.
You can get a certain amount
of megabits of space for free.
And all of a sudden, you
start uploading photos.
Or you're sharing PowerPoint
presentations and documents.
And your friend signs on.
And then all of a sudden,
you tell three other friends.
And they sign on.
And then all of a sudden,
when that is shown as viable,
before you know it, they've
got an entire model here
that is making them a
fortune, because they now
have businesses and
large-- what they call
Pro subscribers, large
users-- paying large dollars
in order to access that data.
It's fantastic.
Does that look like a
complicated business model?
No, not really.
Here's another example
of simplicity rules.
We have the luxury of
leveraging technology.
And we also have different types
of mechanisms in order for us
to educate consumers.
Viral marketing is
certainly one of those
we'll talk about today.
So simply put, your business
model is not your business.
Please remember that.
The business model and
business model innovation
is critical in developing
a quality business,
attacking new markets and
driving profitability.
Just as Bob had shared
earlier, the ability
to modify change and
dwarf your business model
is critical because
just one small change
can make all of the difference.
And we're going to talk
about some companies that
made small changes.
And it's made all of the
difference in their success.
So I'll do the academic
part of this presentation
to give you components
of the business model.
Then we're going to talk
about some good examples.
And then I'm going to leave
plenty of time for Q&A,
and end on time,
as I promised Joe.
So from a business
model perspective,
there's lots of components.
There's aspects of a business
model that should exist.
Overall, they're pretty simple.
What is the value proposition?
What are the market segments
that you're targeting?
What is the value chain?
And what is the structure
of that value chain?
Who's involved in it?
What is your position
within that value network?
Are you at the
early, early stage
from a standpoint
of manufacturing?
Are you at the end stage
from a standpoint of actually
delivering the product or
service to the consumer
or are you somewhere
in the middle?
How do you generate revenue?
And how do you generate margins?
And those are two
very different things.
There are companies
out there we all
know that generate tremendous
amounts of revenue.
And their margins are very
tiny-- 1%, half a percent
or less.
But they make it up because
the revenue is so extreme.
You have other
companies out there
that have exceptionally
high margins, tremendously
high margins, not
very large revenues.
Think about luxury
goods resellers.
Take a look at the
average consumer
that goes out and buys a
luxury bag or a nice suit
or an expensive watch.
Well I can go buy a
watch from Movado.
Or I can go buy a
watch from Swatch.
These are beautiful watches.
They're made by large
manufacturing groups.
They're going through a very,
very sophisticated distribution
channel.
And they're made in
the tens of thousands.
Those watches are sold
anywhere between $39.00,
$49.00 up to probably $1,000.00.
And they're sold
in the thousands
through retailers that
you see in the mall,
through retailers
that are online,
and also through big-box
sellers like Walmart
or Costco or others.
You think, wow,
that's interesting.
Someone like Swatch and also
Movado, which is much higher
end, they both sell through
similar distribution channels.
They do tremendous volume.
So they have very,
very high revenues.
But their margins
are incredibly small.
The goal is saturate the market.
Get as many people
to buy as possible.
Take a look at other
types of products
that are similar that
are called watches.
Very often they're
then called timepieces,
where you have watches that
are handmade, where they're
made in a very, very
subtle way, where it's
a lot of on-hand or craftsman
work and craftsman design,
very low on the
manufacturing side.
It might take months to
make a particular watch,
if not longer.
And the watches sell for
tens of thousands or hundreds
of thousands of dollars.
You think about
IWC, Patek Philippe.
Many of these watches will sell
for $100,000.00 or $50,000.00
for a watch.
Totally different
business model.
Their margins are very large.
But their overall revenues are
relatively small because they
don't sell a lot of pieces.
Think about Mercedes-Benz.
And think about Ford.
If you base success on the
total number of vehicles sold,
Ford kills them year
in and year out.
If you base it on margins,
slightly different story.
Ford has some products that
are incredibly high margins,
like their SUVs.
They have other products,
like their low-end cars
that are very low margins.
But they're looking
to get adoption
within a particular marketplace.
Mercedes, much different story.
Very high margins on virtually
every vehicle they sell.
Much lower volume.
So all of these things have to
be taken into consideration.
You cannot choose your business
model because it seemed like it
made sense, because you
saw a competitor doing it.
You have to figure
out where are you
within that particular
value network.
The competitive strategy
plays into that,
and what stage of
development is the company.
So I'm going to flip through
a couple of these slides.
And we'll dive
into some examples.
And I'm hoping
you guys have lots
of questions at that point.
So the value proposition, which
is really number one here,
is really a description
of the customer problem,
the solution that
addresses that problem,
and the value of the
solution from the customer's
perspective.
The customer's perspective
is very important here.
If I am buying, let's
say an Apple product,
which I see a lot of here,
well there's a lot of things
there that I as a consumer
might be attracted to.
I love the design of it, the
size of it, the feel of it,
the way it operates.
If, for example, you're
buying a desktop computer,
and you chose to
pick out a Dell,
or you chose to pick out
another type of manufacturer,
not like Apple--
maybe you're buying it
for entirely different
reasons than that Apple user.
So think about what is it
that the customer perceives
as value.
Is the customer looking for low
cost or are they looking for
speed?
Are they looking for something?
You need to make sure that your
value proposition offers that.
From a market
segmentation perspective,
it's choosing your audience.
And we could talk about this
entirely throughout this class.
But I'm going to keep it short.
You have to know who that
ultimate end user is.
Who is that person that's
going to write that check,
recognizing that different
market segments have
different needs.
If you're selling,
we'll use the example
I did a moment ago-- if you're
selling to that high-end watch
buyer, who's buying
essentially a timepiece that's
going to be passed down
for generations, that's
a different type of buyer, a
different type of a marketing
approach than if you're
selling a Swatch watch, which
borders on a disposable watch.
If it lasts five
years, it's fantastic.
By then, you probably
have bought three or four
more watches.
Same thing for computers and
cars and many other things.
Additionally value
change structure
and position in the value
network are critical to this.
And they're part of that
initial slide I shared.
So what is the firm's
position in the value chain?
What are the activities
within the value chain?
And how the firm will
capture part of the value
that it creates
within that chain,
because where you fit within
that chain and how much of it
you own is really,
really important to know.
If you're Netflix
think about where
are you in the value chain.
AUDIENCE: Describe
the value chain.
RICH KIVEL: Excellent.
So you asked if I could
describe the value chain.
So think about the entire cycle.
And I'll use Netflix
as an example,
because I mentioned it.
So what does Netflix
do, essentially?
AUDIENCE: They're distribution.
RICH KIVEL: They're
distribution.
To who?
AUDIENCE: End user.
RICH KIVEL: The end user.
They are at the far
end, whichever end
you want to call the far end.
They're at the far
end of the cycle.
There's not much after that.
They're distributing a movie,
something entertaining, to us.
If you think about
that entire value
chain or that entire cycle,
it goes all the way back,
way, way, way back to
somebody, maybe a year ago
or 20 years ago that had an
idea for a picture, an idea
for a movie or a
film, who then as they
moved through that
value chain, maybe
they found a screenwriter.
They ultimately,
perhaps, found a studio.
That studio ultimately
made a decision
whether they were going
to fund it or not,
just like a venture capitalist.
Movies are just like starting
companies-- idea, all the way
through to the business
plan to the funding.
That venture capitalist,
or in the case of a movie,
it's the studio that
says, we love it.
We want it.
The story's outstanding.
We want to buy the story.
We're going to put
this much against it.
They then build the team.
So they find who's
going to be the lead.
Who's going to be the second?
Who's going to be the third?
Who's going to the
action character?
Who's going to be the romantic?
Where is it going to be filmed?
All of these aspects are
just like a business.
They've got to find the
CEO, the CFO, the CTO.
They have to figure
out where are we
going to locate the company.
Where's the best
place for it to be?
And then at that point,
they start working on it,
and toiling away,
and filming it.
And filming could take
weeks, months, or even years.
Then ultimately,
it's distributed.
Now it might be distributed
directly into theaters.
Or if it doesn't
get great reviews
in the early, early
days of distribution,
it might actually
go directly to DVD.
And that's when
Netflix jumps in.
So if you think about
it, that's a long cycle.
And I probably skipped 30 parts.
So where do you fit within
the distribution channel
is absolutely critical
for you to understand
how you think about that, and
where you actually capitalize
and make money.
Netflix also had
the big challenge
where they were facing a major
competitor at that time when
they first came to market.
Does anybody even remember
who that competitor was?
AUDIENCE: Blockbuster.
RICH KIVEL: Blockbuster got
their butt kicked by Netflix.
What happened?
What happened was
two major things.
Number one, technology changed.
DVDs came out.
VCRs were going away.
So videotapes made perfect sense
when you went into Blockbuster.
It was big, bulky, didn't
even think about shipping it,
easy to break.
It gets crushed, doesn't work
so well, tape gets pulled out,
whatever.
Blockbuster had a great model.
They were at the end of the
cycle to us, the consumer.
They put little
stores everywhere.
And they made it easy.
But all of a sudden,
the DVD world
came out, where you
were able to get
super high-definition
quality picture motion
pictures on a DVD that is
as flat as an envelope.
Netflix said, hey,
why are we building
stores for these things?
People already know
the movie they want.
Or they could use this new
technology called the internet,
and figure out what movie they
want, which is mailed to them.
The other big challenge
that Blockbuster had
was the whole process
of limited supply,
and demand on that supply.
So they penalized you if you
don't return the video on time
because they were
losing revenue.
If you didn't get it put
in that little tiny box
by 7:00 AM or 10:00 AM the next
morning, you got charged a fee.
Why?
Because somebody
else wanted their one
of three copies of that movie.
They couldn't have
an unlimited supply.
Whereas the ability
to reproduce and print
DVDs-- virtually unlimited.
Everybody in this
room could order
a DVD today of a hot
movie that just came out.
It could be at your
house tomorrow.
There's no distribution issue.
The ability to reproduce that
DVD, drop it in an envelope,
and mail it to you is
effortless, completely
automated.
So what you have here
is this convergence,
where there was an opportunity.
There was technological
change, whether it
be DVDs or internet or
a combination of both,
that allowed Netflix to
completely crush Blockbuster.
And then Netflix changed
themselves, didn't they?
They recognized that
our ability to capture
more bandwidth, the ability for
us to actually download a movie
was increasing in many
parts of the United States,
not everywhere, not everywhere.
But as our ability,
especially in large cities,
increased to download
movies-- now all of a sudden,
it changed to we don't even
have to ship it to you anymore.
All you have to
do is download it.
It streams to you.
And then they created
a whole series
of other distribution channels.
Now you can get
Netflix on your Roku.
You can get Netflix in
all of these other areas.
So if you think about it, when
the guy that started Netflix
started off, it was
a very simple model.
People like movies.
They're willing to pay for them
so they can watch them at home.
DVDs are the new thing.
And we've developed a complex
shipping method and mechanism
and a model of
warehousing DVDs that we
can get it to people overnight.
And they can keep it
for a day, a week.
We don't really
care, because we're
going to keep shipping more.
It was so simple.
The business model could
not have been easier.
But what they did
is they continued
to change and morph
their business model
as the technology changed.
And they continue to stay
far ahead of the curve.
What is the latest thing
that Netflix is now doing?
AUDIENCE: Producing movies.
RICH KIVEL: They're
producing movies.
How crazy is that?
But can you imagine if you
were the CEO of Netflix
and you said to the
VCs when you went in
to talk to them a decade
ago, well here's the thing.
I got a business idea.
What we're going to do is,
we're going to basically kick
Blockbuster's ass.
We're going to distribute
these things on DVDs.
And then we're going to
start to do downloadable.
And then, by the
way, we're going
to become a movie
production studio.
Their head would explode.
And they would just
say, listen you
have no idea what you're doing.
And you don't understand
how complex the market is.
That's why earlier
I said, simplicity.
When you launch your
business, keep it simple.
Show that that model
is easy to understand.
And then from there
you continue to expand.
Who would have thought
Netflix is now producing some
of the best shows out there?
Orange Is the New Black is one
of the top shows out there,
produced by Netflix.
What are some of the other ones?
AUDIENCE: House of Cards.
RICH KIVEL: House of Cards.
So you think about--
that's mind boggling.
What is the difference between
Netflix and Blockbuster?
Leadership, the ability
to change, the ability
to see around the next
curve, and actually
change the business model of
the company in order to adapt.
So I'll finish up this area of
revenue generation and margins.
We talked a little
about that earlier.
Competitive strategy--
how will the company
attempt to develop and sustain
a competitor advantage?
And I've shared a
little bit about that.
Netflix is a great example.
And then one other
component of this
is where are you on the field?
Understanding where
your business is.
And the Netflix example is
one that is pretty clear.
When you're over in
this area here where
you're pilot testing, and
you're in the gestational area,
or you're doing the roll out,
or you're in slow growth,
that may not be the time to take
on two or three new business
models or enter a different part
of the distribution channel.
But as you start to get
the terminal velocity,
that's the time when you
start to really look back
and say, hey, now let's
take a look at our market
in a different way.
We've got the velocity, whether
it be the funding, the adoption
within the marketplace.
And then at that point,
based on the maturity,
you can start to
think of expanding.
So where are you on the field?
It's always important
to know that.
A lot of companies--
Blockbuster is clearly
one of them-- that took
their eye off the ball,
and they just focused
on what they were doing.
And what they did is just
stuff that we look at now.
We go, gosh, that was so naive.
You thought maybe
eliminating the late fees is
going to solve your problem.
You thought reducing price--
you thought more stores is going
to-- you look at that now.
You say, wow, that's the best
that management team could
come up with.
They were not stepping
back and saying, where
are we on the field, guys?
What's happening in the entire
space that we're playing in?
And where do we play?
A great example is Google.
This is a snapshot of the Google
website launched September 4,
1998.
Isn't that awesome?
Has it changed very much?
Think about it.
How cool is that?
That is elegant.
How simple.
Look at that.
What is it up there?
Index contains 25 million
pages, soon to be much bigger.
How many trillions of pages does
Google have currently indexed?
Think about that.
But what's also important think
about is this-- Google could
have state just like this.
They could have
stayed a simple what?
AUDIENCE: Search engine.
RICH KIVEL: That's it.
Search engine.
It could have been a
great search engine.
They could have been a better
search engine than anyone.
That was what they
were promoting.
We will find you what you're
looking for faster, better.
We prioritize.
We have complex algorithms.
We have a whole bunch
of smart people,
probably from MIT,
that are helping
you find that weird
shit you're looking for.
Seriously.
You're looking for-- you
need a pink doily that
will be eight inches
that is under a lamp
for your grandmother's house.
Or you're looking for
a new hand-held device
for something else.
They're going to
find it for you.
I'm looking to book
a trip to Paris.
They're going to help prioritize
it, best hotels Paris luxury.
Put those in, boom.
Boolean search, we all remember.
Put in all the complex-- the
word plus this are in quotes.
They have better
algorithms than Yahoo.
They have better algorithms than
AltaVista, better algorithms
than NaviSite.
The list goes on.
They could have stopped
there, and just continued
to be the best search
engine in the world.
And you know what?
They're still killing everybody
in search, killing them.
People that like Bing or
others probably disagree.
But I think they kill it.
But what did they
do as a business?
Or I should say,
what didn't they
do since 1998 as a business?
Look at what Google is today.
Give me a few ideas, one
word from a bunch of you.
Just what is Google
today besides search?
AUDIENCE: Brand.
RICH KIVEL: It's a brand.
What?
AUDIENCE: Maps.
RICH KIVEL: Google Maps.
Most of us live on Google Maps.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Mobile.
RICH KIVEL: Mobile.
Think about Google is the
mobile app in so many ways.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Browser.
Email.
RICH KIVEL: I missed that.
AUDIENCE: Email.
Browser.
RICH KIVEL: Email.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH KIVEL: Yep.
What I haven't
heard, maybe somebody
did say is Google is data.
What Google is,
is Google is data.
They have figured out
ways to capture, store,
analyze everything we do.
Google knows more about
us than our families do.
And because of that, they're
able to impact the world.
Do you realize that Google
Health, as an example,
actually provides data,
completely anonymous data,
to groups like the CDC?
If there is an increase
in the number of people
in the Northeast, specifically
Maine, New Hampshire,
Vermont that are in the
increase in searches
around a particular
series of symptoms
at a particular time of year,
that data is actually given
to groups like the CDC to help
think about positioning cures,
positioning vaccines,
and positioning hospitals
and support.
Think about how
powerful that is.
If there is all of a sudden,
thousands of searches,
because a bunch of moms in New
Hampshire, Vermont, and Maine
start Googling high temperature,
all of these symptoms
that might be relevant, or
regular cough or these types
of rashes, and that's regularly
Googled, all of a sudden Google
has a data set where they
can see trends before anyone
else can see them.
They know everything
that's happening
on a very, very global
scale, both micro and macro.
And it really helps
make the world better.
Now people will
get scared and say,
you know it's about privacy
and all these other things.
And I absolutely believe that.
But there is good
that can be created.
This is a data company
that is changing the world.
They know more about you
because of what you search,
how long you hover over a
particular part of a website,
what you do on a regular basis,
the time of day that you do it,
the type of things
that you like,
whether it be the type of
music, the type of concerts,
the type of places you
vacation, the type of hotels
that you shop.
All of those things
are very powerful.
So Google is a data
company, different than what
their original business model
was, or at least appeared
to be.
And part of it is
because of this.
This is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
accidental business model?
Bt they weren't going to
make any money. [INAUDIBLE]
stumbling on [? ad words. ?]
RICH KIVEL: I think so, yeah.
AUDIENCE: --earned them
the money to do all this
stuff. [INAUDIBLE]
RICH KIVEL: I
think you're right.
I think it may have
been accidental.
It might have been the
genius of Eric Schmidt, when
he was put in there by
the venture capitalists.
It might have been a lot
of very smart board people.
It might have been
a lot of factors.
But they harnessed
that opportunity
that everyone else had.
Any of the other search
groups could have done this.
No matter how good the
Google algorithms are,
they're not that
much different, I'm
sure, than some of the
best search out there.
Are they much
different than Bing?
Are they much different
than the other ones?
I don't know.
Are those companies going
to ever become as important
on a global basis as Google?
Think about Google
Maps is great.
What about Google Earth?
How many people here have
not used Google Earth?
Will both of you stand up?
Everybody's used Google Earth.
It's the coolest thing.
If I'm booking a hotel,
and I'm booking a hotel
in the north of Spain-- we go
every year on vacation-- if I'm
booking a hotel and I've never
stayed at a hotel before,
I will look at it
on Google Earth
because I don't believe
the website that
says across the
street from the beach.
It might mean across the
And by the way, the
street is also referred to
as an eight-lane highway.
I'm not going to be
super happy with that
when I show up for vacation.
So I'll Google Earth it.
I'll see where it is.
And I'll be able to
see what's happening.
It's incredibly powerful,
these little things.
And they know I'm
searching that.
So it goes back
to the data piece.
And a lot of it is driven
around this-- the fact
that the change in price
of storage has dropped
so dramatically has transformed
every bit of technology,
whether it be the ability for
Netflix to download movies
or store them, the ability
for you to get on an airplane
right now, and while
you're on that airplane,
instead of watching one
terribly chosen movie coming out
of a ceiling projector, you
have a seat in front of you
that has a screen in it.
And you can pick from 30 movies.
That's just storage.
That plane has enough
storage that we
can pick from 30 different
movies at each seat.
If you're on JetBlue,
you can actually
watch streaming TV as well.
So because of this,
everything's changed.
The rules of the
game have changed.
So the question always is,
what business model, and why?
And if you think about each
of these different businesses
on the surface, if you
didn't know any better,
you would think they were
in the same business.
Apple sells computers.
So does Dell.
Bentley sells cars.
So does Cadillac.
Vertu sells cell phones.
And so does Nokia.
But their distribution
channel and models
are dramatically different.
So I'm going to give you
a few examples of what
I consider really
innovative business models.
Some of these companies we
touched upon already today I'll
touch upon a few of them again.
And we can go into
any more detail
you want or ask questions.
But I think Amazon is
probably one of the greatest
companies out there.
Jeff Bezos is an
absolute genius.
Might be why he's
worth over $20 billion.
He has figured out a
company that he started,
based on the concept of selling
books online and harnessing
what was called user
groups or essentially
peer-to-peer communication
in order to provide reviews.
That was the initial concept.
We're going to
sell books online.
And we're going to harness the
power of the internet, where
people provide feedback about
the books they purchased.
Were they happy with it?
Was it good?
Was it-- et cetera.
We take all this for granted
now, because since then we
can pick movies that way.
We can pick
restaurants that way.
We can pick hotels that way.
That user experience is there.
But Amazon has gone
far bigger than that.
So I look at the
Amazon business model.
I say basically it's a business
model of leveraging assets.
That's the business model.
How many of you
have been following
what Amazon's doing lately?
A couple of big
announcements at Amazon
in the past 30 days,
the 60 Minutes special.
How cool is that?
If anything, it could just
be a project of Bezos.
But think about just the idea of
the drone concept of delivering
packages in a way that
actually reaches the consumer,
essentially the goal being
the same day that they order.
So they've got
this drone concept
that is going to allow these
robotic drones to provide
people packages.
Now we all know there's
lots of red tape there.
You've got-- you've got
the approval of the FAA.
You've got all these
other governmental issues.
But the fact that they
are thinking that far out
of the box-- think about this.
I'm going to use that
example from before.
Imagine if Jeff Bezos walked
into his investors and said,
yo dude.
I need some money
because I got this idea.
We're going to
sell books online.
And people are going
to tell us whether they
like the books or
not, which will then
enforce whether we
sell more books or not,
whether we carry
that author anymore.
And then soon, we're going to
have drones delivering stuff.
It's crazy.
What can't you buy
on Amazon right now?
It's amazing.
I can buy tools on Amazon.
I can buy anything on Amazon.
The drones is one thing.
The latest one that came
out this week was fantastic.
What was the other
release that they
were talking about this
week regarding Amazon?
I'm sorry.
Say it louder.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH KIVEL: Exactly.
Did you hear the new word
that came out for this?
This is definitely going to
be one of those things that's
in the 2014 anticipatory--
so it's anticipatory consumer
something or other.
I don't even
remember what it is.
I just heard it this week.
I loved it.
This is going to be
one of those things
that next-- at the
end of this year,
it'll be the new word that
falls in to the dictionary.
The concept that they
know so much about us
that they can actually begin to
anticipate what we might buy,
very similar to how Google
is a data company-- they can
anticipate what we're going
to click on next-- Google
can pretty much tell
so much about you, just
on what you're clicking
on next, and the speed
at which you do it, and how
long you spend on a website.
Amazon does exactly
the same thing.
We all go on to Amazon now.
And it will say, other people
that purchased that product
also bought these eight.
Or here is your last purchases.
Here's some
recommendations for you.
It's gotten so good that
it's so much-- I don't even
understand why people
do junk male anymore.
It blows my mind.
I get stuff in junk mail for
clearly not my demographic,
stuff that might be perfect
if I was a 17-year-old girl
or an 88-year-old guy.
I'm like, why are they
advertising that to me?
It's amazing.
It's even when it just
shows up, it's in my mail.
I'm talking about inbox.
So this stuff comes in.
You think, what a wacky
way to make money.
Amazon's got it down.
They recommend things
that make sense
to me because they take a look.
I've been an Amazon
member for years.
They can say, listen these
are the kind of books
this guy's ordered.
This is the kind of
music he's ordered.
This is the kind of other stuff.
Hey, we have some
recommendations.
They're not recommending
to me silly things
that just don't make sense.
So now Amazon going to this next
approach, which is absolutely--
it's so MIT-ish, I loved it.
It is algorithmically driven.
It is anticipatory shopping,
that anticipatory experience,
where they actually
believe that they're
going to reach a
point where they have
such familiarity with you, that
they have an idea what you are
likely to buy next, based
on prior purchasing habits,
based on the time of day, the
time of year, you name it,
that what they're envisioning
is that they will actually begin
to ship those things to the
closest warehouse to you,
and deliver to them to you
that day or the following day.
It's mind boggling.
All-around data.
Amazon's incredible.
They're leveraging assets.
Apple-- we could talk
about them for years.
Has anybody here seen
the Steve Jobs movie?
I just watched that, coming
back from California last week.
That thing-- what
a fantastic movie.
And Ashton Kutcher did a
fantastic job as Steve Jobs.
But the genius of
this guy really
spoke about why Apple succeeded.
And it was a great story
about how he started, and got
kicked out, and came back.
But it's really providing
convenient solutions.
Apple is about quality design.
And stuff better
work the first time.
When you plug it
in, it better sync.
When you go to the app
store, it better be there.
It better download.
If it doesn't-- it's
incredible how good they are.
It's all about convenience.
That is a totally
different model
than virtually every other
computer company out there.
Dell's a great company,
has a different model.
We're going to build it custom.
You tell us what you want in it.
We're going to modify it
any which way you wish.
And we're going
to ship it to you.
It's not the Apple model.
Who would have thought
years ago-- many of you
may not even remember,
but years ago there
was no such thing
as Apple stores.
How do you buy an
Apple computer?
Well you bought it
primarily online.
There were very few
distributors of Apple computers.
Apple started off selling
to large school systems
and others.
And now the Apple Store is as
common in cities in the United
States and towns as a Starbucks.
What a different model that
is-- totally mind boggling.
When most people were moving
away from retail box stores--
those expensive locations--
and moving to everything
being internet, Apple
said no, no, no.
We want to be closer
to the consumer.
We want the experience
to be superb.
We want them to be part
of this experience.
They've then opened stores.
And they're making
tremendous money doing that.
Who knows Etsy?
These guys are
cool, aren't they?
What a neat idea.
Doing good on a global basis,
something that could never
been done years ago--
a business model
where they basically
figured out ways
to harness the
power of creativity,
the power of different parts
of the world, people living
in small villages building
beautiful things that
would never be seen outside
of probably a 500-mile radius
of their village,
if that, are now
part of this very
special network
where they can build things.
And you can go online.
And you can purchase them.
And a very small
piece is kept by Etsy.
And most of it goes back to
the artist, to the individual.
It's phenomenal, the thought
that somebody sitting
in Peru or Uganda, or somebody
sitting in a far part of Russia
that builds beautiful
things is actually
selling them to people
sitting in Japan or in Paris
or in Boston.
It's absolutely incredible.
Other innovative models Zara
is probably my favorite.
Everybody here knows
Zara at this point.
I love Spain.
And I love Zara.
They're an absolutely
mind boggling story.
Who thought one company could
innovate an industry that
has been stagnant and
without innovation
as the fashion industry?
The fashion industry has
operated the same way
for about 100 years.
They have models.
They have designers.
They have magazines.
The only innovation,
the only innovation
that's actually hit
the fashion industry
is they sell some stuff online.
They outsource manufacturing.
They've been doing
that for 75 years.
They have expensive
high-paid designers.
And they basically have
a distribution channel
through retail.
It's been exactly the same way.
The challenge is that many
people who want high fashion
can't afford high fashion.
These guys came in and
revolutionized the market.
And their business model
was harnessed and built
around time-to-market.
That is the business model.
They put people at every
fashion show that's important.
They're in New York,
Paris, Milan, everywhere.
And those people are
there taking sketches,
taking digital photos, and
those things they believe
the Zara consumer would want.
Those things are imaged, sent
back instantly to the factory.
50% of all Zara products
are made in Spain.
They're sent back.
They're built. And they're
sent to the stores.
Virtually none of the
products you find in the Zara
last in the store
more than four weeks.
And they will not continue
to replenish them.
They've created this concept
of scarcity, this concept
that what you're
buying is high fashion
and it's in a limited supply.
That is fantastic, compared
to you go to Macy's.
And there's 800 of
the same sweaters.
And there's 8,000 of
the same men's shirts.
And if I go to a different
Macy's, it's exactly the same.
There's no sense
of scarcity there.
Very low design,
very high volume.
However, if I walk
into the Armani shop
on Newbury Street or the Fendi
shop, and look at the bags,
there's a sense of scarcity--
high price, limited resource.
This is this year's bag.
This year's jacket.
Zara basically turned it on its
head and said, no, no, no no.
We're going to have scarcity
and volume and price.
And they nailed it
on all of those.
You don't ever see the Zara
stuff of at Marshalls and T.J.
Maxx, do you?
Because they don't
have excess inventory.
The reason you can walk
into Marshalls and T.J. Maxx
and pick up Burberry and Cartier
and all these other brands
is because Bloomingdale's
and Macy's and all of them
overstocked on them.
The season changed.
They don't know what
to do with the stuff.
So they slash price 60% off, 70%
off, 80% off, then boom, it's
off to Marshalls.
And those companies have created
an entirely different business
model of getting high-quality
goods to consumers.
Zara said, no, no, no.
We're not playing that game.
Let me ask you this.
When's the last time you saw
a Zara advertisement on TV?
It doesn't exist.
When's the last time you saw
a Macy's one-day sale on TV?
Once a day.
Entirely different business
model, same industry.
Zara is amazing.
I want to finish off
these with Gillette who's
absolutely just fantastic.
Gillette, right here
in Massachusetts.
You see them on your
way to the airport.
This is the company that created
the concept-- they created
the first ever disposable
razor, which is a fantastic
concept, back in the '20s.
They then decided
that they were going
to stay at the cutting
edge of technology.
Gillette has over 1,000 patents
just around the Mach3 razor.
They have thousands of patents
within their entire portfolio.
And they will not start
creating a new razor
until almost a patent life
has expired on the existing
razors on the market.
They do not want to
compete against themselves.
They've created this mechanism.
It's absolutely mind boggling.
We get the Mach3
razor as a [? base ?].
It comes off the assembly
line in the United States.
If you go to other countries,
especially developing
countries, they're
getting the razor
that was hot here five years
ago because they realize
that they can sell it
for a third of the price
in large quantities.
Those countries can't
afford the Mach3.
But they can afford the one
that was five years ago,
eight years ago.
And they're buying
them by the millions.
And in addition to that,
they created that concept
of the razor-blade concept.
It's essentially,
you've got the razor.
All you have to do is just
keep buying the blades
and buying the blades.
And they can charge whatever
they want for the blades.
Or you have to start fresh
with Schick or somebody else.
So it's a fantastic concept
of high quality, patents
there in order to
maintain their position
within the marketplace, and
also customer stickiness.
We gave them this pretty razor.
It's beautiful.
It's got metal on it.
It's got nice colors.
They're just going to
keep buying the blades,
buying the blades,
and buying the blades.
So it's a fantastic series
of different business
models within one.
Other ones we're
all familiar with
are great groups
like Kickstarter,
PayPal are really leveraging
the whole P2P revolution.
It's absolutely
amazing what you see.
Craig's List is a
fantastic example of that.
Their website is about as
sexy as the Google page.
There's really nothing
attractive about it.
But it's an incredibly
successful business.
We talked about Dell.
They built their
entire success around
the just-in-time concept.
We're going to build a computer
exactly the way you want it.
In addition to that, you've got
the one day, one deal business
model.
We're all familiar
with our inboxes
full of Living Social
and Groupon and all
these other groups.
In addition to that,
you've got other groups
like Priceline, which I think is
a phenomenal model, and really
unique advertising too.
They've taken an approach,
unlike a lot of these groups
here who you never see on TV.
Priceline has taken the approach
of using somebody like Shatner
or other people that basically
get them excited about-- you
set your price,
you're in control.
And some of us love that.
Some people love Priceline.
I have friends that use
Priceline all of the time.
Some of us just jump on.
And we just go to expedia.com.
And we book our hotel.
Or we go to the new
one, Hotel Tonight,
which is my favorite
app, especially when I'm
going to different cities.
You jump onto Hotel Tonight,
entirely different model.
They only list hotels after
12:00 in the afternoon.
They cut these special deals
with the hotels for that night.
So you wind up staying
at fantastic places
because they knew at 11:55
they had availability.
They released the
rooms to Hotel Tonight.
Hotel Tonight kills hotels.com,
another one, that day.
It might not be the way to
book a seven-day vacation.
But if you're looking for
two nights in New York City,
it's phenomenal.
It's all on your app,
not on the website.
You can't even do
it on the website.
Uber's another fantastic
example of that.
Instant gratification,
car-service quality,
not a taxi cab, all
web-based, all app-based.
So to summarize, value
proposition, market segment
and value chain are really
understandings that you
have to have in this area of
developing a business model.
Where do you sit in the network?
Exactly where are
you on the field?
And revenue generation
and margins-- those
are two different things.
You have to think about
what's important to you.
Are you going to be a
high-margin business,
low volume?
Are you going to be a
high-revenue business
and low margin?
Or are you going to try
to do what Apple does,
which is a combination of both?
Where do you fit within
the competitive landscape?
And of course, the stage of
development of your company
is critical.
Where are you within that
particular growth cycle?
And always remember
that success consists
from going from
failure to failure
without a loss of enthusiasm.
And I'll close there.
Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]